I can't imagine what's or secret or
calves
he died
excuse the nerves as my word
try read it though I have had sex with
men I've had a bit of work done well
does that mean I'm sorry I left your pet
rabbit Benji in a car park you know I
said it went live in the country yep
well it didn't really I don't think I've
been the best parent don't think I've
been the best person out there why well
in a nutshell fobbed you off didn't do
my father need to tease and I feel very
bad for that yeah
I'm not I'm not gay I just fooled around
and paused mister like it
yeah you know what I've set up actresses
and things and I've said all she's had a
bit of work done I just have a little
bit of them Botox
around here yeah
when I had my mom's funeral and you know
you said you can make it because some
fee that kind of hurt me in a way
because I needed you there and it's
supposed to help with migraines as well
so that's my excuse well that's
definitely us cuz because I'm sure
that's not what you do
I mean I went down the wrong road in
history I went down the drugs road I'm
still paying debts from those days even
though I'm well away from it now I know
how you feel with your mom younger son
yeah well I lost minor the age of sub
now you told me don't get me wrong
hush saying properly I have issues we
make promises and I don't deliver a lot
of the times it's only due to financial
you know restrictions it's not about
them the money you know I'm not in the
financially amazing pages Eva but I want
to still be there for my son all the
time as much as I possibly can
it hit me really when obviously oh
you're just being like your dad
and you don't know you and that was like
one of the moments I was just that
I'm actually gonna cry I have been
ashamed of my sexuality what the heating
when always being bullied or the
pressure school and the pressure of
everything being a teenager you're the
first person who made me feel like I
could do or say what wanted to even for
my fun mm-hmm
you deserve you don't deserve to be
buddy khushu you're amazing
you better walk to me and I couldn't
picture my life without you
that's just being a girl and you
understand has been real I doesn't
change anything from marry me man yeah I
wasn't sure how you'd react well how
much does it cost a hundred where for Oh
I'll endeavor to stop bullshitting and
get on with it I'm not sure going over
there I'm done for the night I describe
a bit he's the biggest sort of casualty
of humanity almost is the lack of
communication it's the thing that breaks
most relationships down it just feels so
much better the toes and just get it out
you
man yeah your day yeah right
uh no you can't wear that the economy
the future of humanity yeah there's one
area where many of us retain a curious
sense of optimist